I was going to ask you snapchat
Instagram what do you do both and we
kind of figured you'd say it so what do
you do first both at the same time yeah
you're not you're not going snapchat
then taking that video yeah I mean
honestly that's just a cadence that's a
moment in time like that's a however you
feel like which one you like but anybody
who's listening right now that wants to
make something happen you're gonna build
the next biggest clothing line both you
want to get some new customers for your
bakery shop both you want to get a job
interview at a social media shop both
like if you have ambition your actions
have to match that and too many people
are just like not putting in the work
their mouth is way ahead of their
[ __ ] reach you know actions like
really you're gonna be the greatest NBA
player of all time why cuz you think you
got a little handle on the weekends you
need to shoot 15,000 free-throws before
school every day to me the answer is
both and it's not even a foot like when
people are business like if you're a
normal person if my brother-in-law is
like what should I do for my life I
don't care one or the other but if
you're a business person or you have
ambitions or you want to run for office
or whatever you want to do both always
end and Twitter and Facebook and YouTube
and SoundCloud and and and and both
[Music]